welcome to this video playing
international master koblenz as a name
danny deever knee yo that's a very
strong play actually is a very good GM
already he hasn't bothered to to tell
ICC I guess that he's a grandmaster now
and let's test this wacky line again
it's just funny maybe what about this I
think but okay I think there is T takes
you for actually I can I'll take it play
this this line okay it's the some way to
avoid this Bishop g4 stuff maybe 95
don't want to I want him to so easily
exchange the light squared Bishop maybe
I can make some sense out of the age
from by playing a h5 after all
yeah this guy him dominated the villainy
think he's close to 2600 by now pretty
pretty good good Grandmaster some
proofed considerably in the last year
yes whatever we sometimes let's put it
like that okay do I go queen bee three
here or how do I protect the Batu Khan
hmm not sure if the queen bee three this
double point is not a big issue that
don't really see how else to do it okay
let's let's play that
I have h5 to make you know now I don't
have it to make some sense of the all of
the of this habit okay it's not a big
deal here i can think of taking and play
night a 4 that's 97 okay taking Bobby 5
is also move
hmm difficult let's let's control some
squares a 4g phone I can still do those
things and I have kinky to which I
didn't like before because of sometimes
maybe 90 for anything kinky to Roxy one
that's what I'm going to play don't
worry I'm not quite sure what he's doing
now Bishop f5 maybe Bishop to e6 maybe
he's preparing 97 now that's possible 97
I can think about just retreating to d3
and tending like be four and 95 I can
just take oh yeah thought night a 4
might be a good move and so let's go for
that not think about it too long yes but
I now I'm getting rid of my problem
pieces and like the dark squared bishop
and i have b 4 95 in the mix it looks
quite nice this is a very good version
of the slovaks change the king is in
play and he does not have a substantial
counterplay v5 of course this is what he
can try to prepare yeah like Bishop f7
and e5
it's still quite nice I am have them the
better bishop from a pawn structure
point of view he's got quite some points
on light squares that's not very
comfortable to play this position
tricky rb67 Hank say six so i will i
will come with 95 just a just a very
nice position and where exactly is black
scaled to play g5 maybe g5 something
like that but not sure that it is
helping and much okay that was the idea
take here it looks very unnatural this
stuff takes tags there is no direct wind
which is somewhat surprising almost it
looks really weird this sir this move
right is six books you will it's no
tactical way to exploit that it's really
hard to believe but maybe it's the case
okay come on not not that's not to lose
on time it's not ideal on the capture
edit keeps her keeps the pressure on
really Roxy one I thought 57 but ok Rob
c7 yeah maybe he can advance with the
King and keep things up on the control
6v6 this book c6 Bishop d7 II also
cannot play maybe like that okay I same
time warning I seem ruki a German okay
i'll probably app he defended as well oh
I plated the plated badly also possible
I is trying to to do something even g5
and I can play rook c8 I think being a
somewhat lower on time I can I can I
become now ki can try that it's not
really a risk or anything
this is surprising I mean okay it's it's
probably still a draw but the only one
that that is some kind of chances he has
wide he at least has got some points on
light squares
but should be 62 f 7 s my idea maybe
there are some some kind of zoom swung
in there probably not check note that
i'm not playing on time here this is
just a better position four ID it's
probably a draw but i can try to play
for a win here check this is a draw i
think at least if he if he just stays
here there's no way to draw there's no
way to do it I mean now I've even below
on time this is the problem with
offering a draw sometimes it at least
for me it costs like two seconds and
then the other guy can actually turn it
around and try to win on time but here
think he is just nothing nothing left I
was thinking maybe he maybe had a little
bit here somewhere but it probably was a
draw it probably was a drawn I had a
very nice position here which would
interest me this this King this defense
was quite quite cured with King f7 and
then look c7 yeah the computer does not
find anything great as well it gives me
five yeah maybe b5 is the move could be
like that
yeah yeah probably something like that
but hmm it's not it's still not totally
clear if it's winning for white I mean
winning is this a bit much to ask
forward if it is really a big edge of
what I still some play with g5 and very
very tough very tough the same it looks
very nice that's a really cute defense
this is not leading to anything funny
enough yeah this is what always is
possible but I don't know Black has some
substantial counter player with the
pawns I mean something like that I
didn't calculate that I'm just just had
a bad feeling about it this was the
stuff coming in the Jeep on falling I
don't know a computer gives it a zero
zero zero which I find surprising I
would sort of thought that it would be
good for some site but not they're not
equal a very tough game alright thanks
for watching